ja vielen Dank Hans zu einer schönen
guten Tag meine Damen und Herren es war
in der Tat ein einzigartiger Vorgang den
wir da erlebt haben im Oktober das
Machtwort des Bundeskanzlers war ja
nichts anderes als die Ausübung seiner
Richtlinienkompetenz er hat dann einen
weisen Mittelweg gewählt die Bündnis
Grünen wollten ja eigentlich die
Atomkraft zum 31.12 auslaufen lassen
haben danach gebessert dass ganze hätte
dann also als vorratsreserve dienen
sollen zwei südliche AKWs bis zum April
die FDP hat dagegen gehalten hat gesagt
nein wir brauchen in der jetzigen
Situation jede Energie die wir
gebrauchen die wir holen können und
deswegen war die FDP sogar dafür die
drei Atomkraftwerke auch noch zwei Jahre
laufen zu lassen in Deutschland der
Kanzler hat dann bekanntlich den
Mittelweg vorgegeben die Atomkraftwerke
alle drei werden in einen streckbetrieb
gehen und am 15 April soll dann Schluss
sein mit der Atomkraft ganz wichtig ist
sollen keine neuen Br Gewebe gekauft
werden das ist der Kompromiss um den es
heute geht eigentlich muss man natürlich
sagen eine Verlängerung der Laufzeiten
nämlich bis zum 15.4 muss der Bundestag
heute beschließen mit der Mehrheit der
Ampel und so wird es dann
voraussichtlich auch kommen aber ich
kann mal nachfragen bei meinen heutigen
Gästen ich begrüße ganz herzlich Harald
Ebner er ist der Vorsitzende des
Ausschusses für Umwelt Naturschutz
nukleare Sicherheit und
Verbraucherschutz und Steffen Bilger
begrüße ich den stellvertretenden
Fraktionsvorsitzenden der
cdu/csu-fraktion für diesen Bereich
zuständig Herr Bürger ich habe es gerade
so ein bisschen
Herr Ebner ich habe es gerade so ein
bisschen beschrieben wie sauer sind die
Grünen eigentlich noch auf den
Bundeskanzler
wir sind gar nicht sauer aber lassen Sie
mich eins sagen weil sie sagen die
Grünen wollten zum 31.12 Schluss mit der
Atomenergie machen das waren einstimmige
Beschluss des Deutschen Bundestages im
Juni 2011 also die ganze Republik der
gesamte Bundestages war einstimmig es
waren Gesellschafts politischer Konsens
ein gesellschaftlicher Konsens zum 31.12
diesen Jahres aus der Atomenergie
auszusteigen und das ist bis jetzt
geltende Rechtslage richtig aber dann
kam der Krieg und die Probleme die damit
einhergehen und deswegen noch mal die
Frage damit was gleich mal festmachen
werden die Grünen denn heute dieser
Verlängerung der Laufzeit bis zum April
zustimmen es wird für uns ja nicht
einfach wir hatten eine Notfallreserve
für zwei Kraftwerke im Süden das wäre
auch sachgerecht gewesen was die Energie
technischen Fragen angeht vorgesehen
wir tun uns schwer mit jedem Tag den die
Atomkraftwerke länger laufen wir können
aber gut damit leben dass keine neuen
Brennstäbe das ist für uns die rote
Linie dass keine neuen Brennstäbe
beschafft werden dass kein neuer
Atommüll anfällt weil die Endlagersuche
ist bis heute ungelöst insoweit tragen
wir die heute zur Abstimmung stehende
Lösung den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung mit Herr Müller man
merkt den Grünen fällt das erkennbar
schwer logisch ist es ja eine Art
gründungs DNA gegen Atomkraft zu sein
die Union sieht das ein bisschen anders
sie sagt wir haben eine Notlage wir
wollen die AKWs länger laufen lassen
nämlich bis zum 31.12 24 warum dieser
Termin und ihnen ist schon klar das
haben sie auch reingeschrieben dass sie
neue Brennstäbe brauchen und da sagen
viele Experten also wenn man neue
Brennstäbe einsetzt dann müssen die auch
mindestens drei vier Jahre besser
brennen warum also 24 Ende
wir sind in einer Energiekrise und ich
glaube allen ist bewusst dass wir da
wirklich vom großen Problem stehen
deswegen hat die Ampel sich auch
durchgerungen zu diesem Minimalkonsens
zumindest die Laufzeiten bis April zu
verlängern um über diesen Winter zu
kommen aber das wird nicht reichen denn
der kommende Winter darauf folgende
Winter 23 24 wird vorausgedicht noch
härter werden also dieser Minimalkonsens
in der Regierung reicht nicht aus in der
Tat der große Unterschied zwischen den
beiden Gesetzentwürfen die heute zu
Abstimmung stehen wir plädieren dafür
neue Brennstäbe zu beschaffen die
Laufzeiten mindestens bis Ende 24 zu
verlängern wir haben in unserem
Gesetzentwurf auch eine Evaluierung
vorgesehen das sind dann im Sommer 24
überprüft ob ein nochmalige Verlängerung
nötig ist wir stehen zum Atomausstieg
aber ich glaube in der jetzigen
Situation es ist einfach nicht
verantwortungsbewusst aus politischen
Gründen diese Option wegzugeben wo wir
nicht wissen ob wir wirklich
Versorgungssicherheit gewährleisten
können wo die Strompreise viel zu hoch
sind wo es auch um eine Frage der
europäischen Solidarität und nicht
zuletzt ja auch um den Klimaschutz geht
dann viel Kohle zu verfeuern statt die
Kernkraftwerke am Netz zu Lasten das
macht ja wirklich nicht so richtig Sinn
hey immer ich zitiere mal die
Umweltministerin Steffi Lemke von den
Grünen aus der ersten Lesung am Mittwoch
sie hat gesagt es wäre absolut
fahrlässig auf diesen Beitrag zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt zu verzichten diese
drei AKWs das ist an Erkenntnis sie hat
sie nicht das ganze Jahr über gehabt und
diese Erkenntnis ist ja auch eine die
die anderen oppositionsverteilen teilen
und sagen deswegen brauchen wir das
wahrscheinlich auch noch im kommenden
Winter wo ist da der Unterschied zum
Winter 23 und da wird ja einiges
ausgeblendet also zum einen die
Erkenntnis ist ja dem zweiten
verschärften Stresstest durch die
Netzbetreiber geschuldet die aber gesagt
hat im Grundsatz können diese drei
Atomkraftwerke kaum und maximal einen
marginalen Beitrag zur Netzstabilität
leisten und schon gar nicht zum
gaseinsparen und schon gar nicht was die
Preise angeht desto der erste Punkt der
der Unterschied zur Union ist dass wir
sagen
wir wollen dass die Kraftwerke zur
Verfügung stehen in dem Fall indem man
sie braucht das hat sich jetzt erledigt
durch den durch den Beschluss der
ansteht sie laufen durch bis zum 15.4
also ein begrenzter Weiterbetrieb bis
längstens 15.04 das ist ein wesentlicher
Unterschied und der der dritte Punkt
wenn ich die Krokodilstränen höre was
den Klimaschutz angeht bei der Union
dann frage ich mich einfach täglich
warum haben wir in den letzten 16
unionsgeführten Jahren in dieser
Republik nicht mehr Klimaschutz gesehen
nicht mehr ausbaut erneuerbaren Energien
und das genau ist das was wir jetzt in
diesem Jahr mit wirklich einer bislang
nie dagewesenen Geschwindigkeit auf den
Weg gebracht haben und das wird auch
sein was uns dann in den und über den
nächsten Winter tragen wird sind sie
auch vorstellen wir haben dafür gesorgt
dass jetzt die Gasspeicher zu 100%
gefüllt sind
letzten Herbst waren die leer wir haben
ein Gesetz geschaffen das dafür sorgt
dass das passiert und wir haben es
geschafft obwohl die russischen
Gaslieferungen komplett ausgesetzt sind
und damit sorgen wir vor und damit
schaffen wir uns auch eine Sicherheit
für die kommenden Jahre weil da der
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren dann auch
massivfahrern kommen wird das Argument
kommt ja immer wieder in den letzten 16
Jahren ist zu wenig passiert man
bräuchte eigentlich mehr erneuerbare
Energie die hat man jetzt aber nicht und
interessanterweise hat man auch im
ersten halben Jahr unter der Ampel nicht
mehr Zubau an Windrädern zum Beispiel
als unter der großen Koalition woran
liegt das
ich muss zunächst mal Herrn Ebner
widersprechen also die Bundesregierung
will ja nicht mit mehr erneuerbaren
Energien durch diesen und den nächsten
Winter kommen sondern vor allem mit dem
wieder Anfeuern von Kohlekraftwerken und
das hat mit Klimaschutz dann wirklich
nichts zu tun man kann darüber streiten
was wir bisher in Klimaschutz erreicht
haben in Deutschland muss allerdings
auch darauf hinweisen 1990 hat man sich
ein Ziel gesetzt den CO2-Ausstoß und 40%
zu reduzieren bis 2020 das haben wir
erreicht also wir haben durchaus einiges
geschafft als Industrienation wo wir
auch darauf achten müssen dass wir die
Versorgung mit Energie sicherstellen so
dass es für die Verbraucher zu
bezahlbaren Preis möglich ist und dass
auch die Arbeitsplätze erhalten werden
ich komme aus Baden-Württemberg wir eben
auch hier im Bundestag wird immer den
Bayern und der CSU vorgehalten die
hätten nichts erreicht beim Ausbau der
Windkraft also in Baden-Württemberg in
elf Jahren grüne Umweltminister sieht es
auch nicht anders aus klar wir brauchen
eine Kraftanstrengung sind aber auch
wieder bei Themen wo die Grünen
gefördert sind weil bisher war es halt
oft so dass der Naturschutz oder andere
Fragen
schnelleren Ausbau der wunderbaren
Energien entgegenständen also da müssen
dann auch die Grünen über den Schatten
springen der gipsbewegung das begrüße
ich auch sehr und wir sind absolut dazu
bereit noch mal einen richtigen Schub zu
geben beim Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien denn das ist ja unser
gemeinsames Ziel dass wir irgendwann zu
100% erneuerbaren kommen und die
fossilen Energien nicht benötigen und
auch die Kernkraft nicht mehr benötigen
aber damals noch einen Weg zu gehen aber
ist das nicht auch ein Grund warum die
Bundesregierung und auch die Grünen
Ministerinnen und Minister in der
Bundesregierung jetzt sagen okay für
diesen Jahr für diesen Winter brauchen
wir noch Atomkraft auch weil man die
Erkenntnis gewonnen hat dass eben die
Kohlekraftwerke gar nicht so schnell ans
Netz gehen können
genau das ist ja der Punkt darauf habe
ich vorhin hingewiesen der Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren wurde ja behindert in den
letzten 16 Jahren
aus dieser Erkenntnis heraus wir können
ja nicht Windräder einfach herzaubern
weil sie schon gesagt haben in den
ersten sechs Monaten ist da noch nichts
passiert ich meine sie haben einen
Planungsvorlauf in sechs Monaten bauen
sie auch kein Windrad so also das heißt
wir haben jetzt Hürden aus dem Weg
geräumt die die Union aufgebaut hat es
waren wahnsinnig viele Schikanen im
Übrigen auch für die binnen für die
Windkraft an Land gerade in
Baden-Württemberg da kamen gar keine
Anträge mehr obwohl wir in
Baden-Württemberg das von der Union
damals geschaffene verhinderungsrecht
aufgehoben haben damit diese diese
windkraftplanung schneller vorankommen
kann so also vor diesem Hintergrund
haben wir gesagt wir müssen alles
beschleunigen was geht
die lng-terminals die gebaut werden auch
noch mal auf Kohle und Öl zurückgreifen
aber lassen Sie mich das auch sagen wir
müssen auch einsparen dazu gibt es auch
Incentives Anreize für die für die
Industrie und Vereinbarungen und es
gerade heute morgen hat die
Bundesnetzagentur auch noch mal
mitgeteilt oder was gestern um also wie
viel eingespart wurde die Industrie ich
glaube zwischen 20 und 30 Prozent und
die Privathaushalte sogar fast 50
Prozent das muss man sich mal vorstellen
das ist eine unglaubliche Leistung die
wir da alle zusammen die die Menschen in
diesem Land alle zusammen hinbekommen
haben und in der Summe in der Summe sind
wir überzeugt dass wir mit diesen
Maßnahmen gut über den Winter kommen
dass wir mit diesen Maßnahmen auch nicht
unsere Klimaziele gefährden denn
gleichzeitig haben wir heute in der
ersten Lesung auch die Vereinbarung den
Kohleausstieg der Union um acht Jahre
vorzuziehen wir steigen acht Jahre
zumindest mechanischen Revier schon mal
acht Jahre vorher aus der Kohle aus und
damit bleiben bleiben Millionen Tonnen
Kohle im Boden und werden nicht
verfeuert das ist ein echter Beitrag zum
Klimaschutz Klimaziele nicht verfehlen
das ist ein gutes Stichwort denn gestern
gerade hat die deutsche Delegation viel
Kritik von internationalen Professoren
und Wissenschaftlern gekriegt für die
Tatsache dass hier LNG Terminals
aufgebaut werden bei der internationalen
Konferenz Umweltkonferenz das ist ja in
der Tat auch nicht so einfach mit diesen
g Terminals sie sind jetzt erstaunlich
schnell aus dem Boden gestampft worden
das erste wird wohl schon kommende oder
ich glaube kommende Woche eingeweiht
dass er schneller als man in Deutschland
je erwarten konnte aber ganz ohne sind
diese lngs ja auch nicht es gibt großes
Unverständnis in Europa und in der Welt
über die aktuelle Energie- und
Klimapolitik dieser Bundesregierung also
Beamte aus dem
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium aus dem
Bundesumweltministerium haben in Entwurf
das prüfvermerks vom März zur Frage der
Weiternutzung der Atomkraft
reingeschrieben wenn die Atomkraftwerke
weiter betrieben werden im
Leistungsbetrieb dann bedeutet das 25
bis 30 Millionen Tonnen CO2-Einsparung
pro Jahr das ist eine Riesensumme das
die Hälfte dessen was die Landwirtschaft
pro Jahr in CO2-Emissionen
verantwortlich ist und das gibt man
einfach weg macht stattdessen mehr Kohle
baut lng-terminals wir unterstützen den
Bau der lng-terminals aus unserer Sicht
nötig ist um unsere Energieversorgung zu
sichern wir müssen jetzt eben alles tun
damit die Verbraucher die Sicherheit
haben dass auch die Unternehmen die
Sicherheit haben aber solche
Entscheidungen Kernkraft abzuschalten
oder auch andere Fragen die wir zurzeit
diskutieren die Bundesregierung wollte
die Förderung für kleine
Wasserkraftwerke streichen sie wollte
die Möglichkeiten beim Biogas Deckeln
das sind alles seltsame Entscheidungen
wenn es eigentlich heißt es kommt auf
jede Kilowattstunde an und wir wollen
auch den Klimaschutz ernst nehmen
vielen Dank dass sie da waren es
klingelt nämlich und Sie müssen dringend
rein weil sie einer der ersten Redner
sind Herr Ebner da sind wir gespannt ich
wollte nur sagen Klimaschutz
ist sehr wichtig wir müssen gleichzeitig
aber die nukleare Sicherheit genauso ins
Kalkül ziehen und wenn wir uns etwas
einkaufen eine Kilowattstunde wir können
die uns nicht um jeden Preis einkaufen
nämlich nicht um den Preis eines
erhöhten nuklearen Risikos und den
vermeiden wir diesen Preis vermeiden wir
vielen Dank